brought to you by assassin's creed unity
make history with friends available now
happy birthday everybody and welcome to
top 5 scary months of the week Seb is it
my birthday it uh no oh your birthday
you know what it actually isn't is your
birthday at home it might be almost
certainly someone's yes but I can tell
you whose birthday it definitely is or
was yesterday who's that
Skyrim yes birthday Skyrim you are
exactly three yesterday being the 11th
of November yeah was skyress third
birthday was before we get how we're
gonna celebrate Seb let's not forget
again to do step 5 we won't share we
won't forget because we never forget
ever we usually forget it's from game
discussion one who says scorpion is a
good look alike but I think the Breton
night from last week's episode who most
looks like Eve from Mass Effect 3 and I
gotta say yep pretty ugly scene yet the
Eve's Krogan right the big Kruger person
yes the Rogen female yes yes it wasn't a
very very good shout like you very much
but cam yes how are we gonna celebrate
well it's Skyrim as we just said it's 3
which is insane to what we're gonna do
in dog years that's like a hundred oh
yeah in Kevin years that's like a drop
in the ocean you know it's barely a
blink of an eye Kevin doesn't perceive
time yeah so you know ages is neither
here nor there really true but how are
we gonna set up what we're gonna do
except this we want to really show how
Skyrim has changed from the vanilla sky
wheel like was what we're crazy about
three years ago to what it's become now
with the power of mods so we are we ever
allowed ourselves not 5 no but double
that Wow 10 mod I was gonna say 11 but
10 yet would've been close a nice double
college try dumb maths well den is
double 10 whole mods so what we've done
is we've actually got a whole new PC and
we've done a fresh install with just ten
we got rid of all arrests we forced
ourselves to you know to pick the 10
most essential mods if you were to
reroll in Skyrim three years on that's
exactly we're gonna do in this episode
so let's get to it
sab welcome to the character creation
screen and our very first mod of this
reroll which is I recognize this this is
alternate start live another life which
I would describe as basically the
perfect mod for re-rolling yes because
it basically means you don't do go
through that all the stuff at the
beginning with the dragon attack and all
that you can just jump straight into
kind of a scenario of your choosing
yeah hey Peetie of choosing Zeb yes
would you want to go van nor I love it's
perfect idea for a role great name are
curious oh wow absolutely love it now
what this does is it puts you into this
basically dungeon I guess yeah um all is
not lost because there's a statue of
Mara and I think if you activate it
let's begin so you basically just get to
decide who you were so uh something a
little different because you know we're
obviously going for a very different
kind of character yeah yeah very
different
I like necromancer in a secret location
let's go for that one there uh-huh
here we are completely a second chance
started live another life ah
complete with free stuff again your new
life okay and this is home we're in a
rather oh yes comes with a skirt of the
skeleton that what I'm learning already
is that we're starting off with a big
old leg up by comparison okay so things
are beginning quickly but it does stick
you right in the wild so you know it
could be quite a could be quite tricky
the first thing you might recognize
yourself is this is not vanilla sky'
room here in the fat that is not the UI
that we you would normally have if you
were to boot this game up say three
years ago I guess anyone who's been
watching this show will recognize this
UI because we just used it forever
yeah but this UI is called Skye UI yes
and it makes navigating especially on PC
when you're using a mouse and keyboard
of course we're using controller yet
much easier much much easier
everything's much more easily organized
as well so this is new Kevin sir beaser
got a dagger I love the fur collar yeah
I'd like to added that yeah it's is
really wait to catch a chill said but
it's not just that I think he was like
well I liked the outfit but something is
different
it's not helping like I'd want I don't
know why he's got that accent oh no
cause it's never spoken a word in his
life oh um doesn't actually have a voice
oh geez oh hell flow Wow oh no way this
is gonna be a tricky old fight well that
story well oh my god that's how that
happened how how do we escape from here
oh god it's gonna load us up here every
enemy just just run Kevin bungees it
these are words I never thought I'd say
run Kevin van Norden uh yeah I've had to
run in his life stamp stammers no oh my
god he's got nothing I said when you
make it out which we have finally done
finally um where you know in Skyrim in
whatever location your alternate start
gave you currently we are all the way
over here in the middle the mountains
just died already
yeah nice work Kevin Van Doren's Kevin's
pretty handy as a mage nobody never of
thought he's I'm glad to see he's
prepared to accept change
well now the computing power you know we
can harness the the true potential of
Skyrim we have got an ENB and a very
very powerfully and beyond as well which
is probably why it's hammering our
framerate so hard to be the same one
from last week it is of course Kem beep
your lights your reason I've changed
chosen it is not just because of how
powerful it is although that is
important it's because it also has its
own climate weather system built-in yes
and lighting system built-in that's a
rope there's a rope is a rope and that's
a much better Rock than you would have
gotten Vanilla Sky absolutely and that's
just part part of the magic of mod
number 3 which is static mesh
improvement yet you notice oh no no
Gerald's as well MIM yes so it takes all
of the basic framework meshes that you
would have in the game a lot of them are
things like chains ropes bits and pieces
that would normally be quite square like
oh no they didn't go too much trouble of
making sure they looked very genuine and
someone has gone and and remade all of
these meshes to make sure things look
and feel real so in the past those ropes
around the tops the post there would be
really angry
flam yeah and if you're gonna do a
visual overhaul of Skyrim or really any
game and and you leave these things out
they stand out like a sore thumb do it
when you've got you know like EMBs and
textures and all sorts I think we should
try and find the guy who can take us
swiftly to another hold hmm I don't
think he'll be on the cliffs no he may
never know his disobedient horse was
like I hate this weather it's time to
kill myself I will burrow it was too
cold up there steps we've come to
Whiterun that's trying to show off more
of their 10 essential mods I tell you
what you can see the EMB here wait yeah
it looks great
oh the Sun glare that's an amazing
little hint of Sun black hey it's the
tiniest little bit through the wall this
is one of the parts of the CMV which I
usually like to turn off so let's give
that a go Sun glare boink I'm at the
Rays the Rays see the Rays are also not
great they seem to be ignoring your
request for dismissal you really do well
at least just to show it off we should
get the depth of field on just so you
can see how how lovely images really do
he that is pretty extreme intense depth
of field to really show us really I did
pick the most extreme version of it like
last week as well so it is kind of
strong yeah we probably don't want that
one on and all in all fairness okay but
there this looks this really still looks
absolutely great with that with um the
lighting but the textures are new as
well which we haven't talked about yet
services the texture the texture mods do
we have a so it's the same one we've
been using through the show since we
rebuilt our machine which is Skyrim HD
2k textures it is the most popular
texture pack on the Nexus and you can
see why I find the rocks probably look
the most glamorous like you
he's like glamorous glamorous do you do
you not think rocks look collaborative
where the hell were you I may be looking
for you B or lamb you that is your real
name I said one of the other essential
Mars we chose today is all around you
when you boot up Skyrim in fact it is
right here in this iron helmet and in
this heavy target shield probably and
definitely in these weapons what I'm
talking about I'm noticing this shield
rack
is definitely new yes and and the paints
below it what if we activate it ah this
is the immersive armored shield painting
rack you may wish to be in third person
mode warning placing our Apple
destroying any enchantments on it so
this is part of of course immersive
armors yes this is this is such a good
mod in fact it's so good I've paid it up
technically with another mod which is a
immersive weapons you still have the
vanilla weapons and armor you know they
have alternate versions and they just
like the version yeah yeah a much more
exciting and and sometimes much more
suitable for the climate of Skyrim as
well so he can open a shield first yes
of course he can all right how do I do
this then I don't know Alice oh oh
choose shield pattern ah next next
that's not bad next oh I like that one
okay done done ah I guess you did it
okay grace that was easy it okay so
technically we don't actually have any
smithing ability so but but what's
interesting is we do have a new thing
there which is wood oh yeah which is
never there before no think basic things
like practice arrows which do no damage
but are really cheap to make and a
quarterstaff huh yeah Stefan shields Oh
highway highway mail I'm in mail I like
that a lot when we had Kevin bond or
dove previous saves in here this list is
epic because he is a master Smith yeah
well he's master of everything in this
he's still sort of waking up he's a bit
groggy he doesn't really remember how to
make break or mend things
yeah so this mod obviously levels with
you which means it's something that you
could work with re-roll yeah all the way
throughout so as you unlock more you'll
be unlocking more of the mod as well as
you as you level up you'll have better
weapons and armor that you can forge
but for the time being I think maybe we
should forge a new one
that's a nice low level like us is there
any stuff around us we can just have
take these hate these sell them back
yeah I'll quickly read the armors
challenge oh yeah very useful reading
that'll help us
oh you're alone my friend my friend oh
we don't need the Dwarven stuff because
we can't Forge it or the bells there we
go the pelt would be useful for making
the leather yeah whips it let's expand
yeah it is it is we go let's go spend
money to make money SAP yeah there is
you want to kill some people you got to
break a few heads yeah okay let's see
how we can forge now we've done a bit of
business sad look at the highwayman male
we made for a Kevin that looks way more
suitable looks pretty cool it's a mix of
leather fur and and male right yeah that
feels like something that someone on the
highway would be like I can afford a bit
of this a bit of that I don't think he'd
quite wear the circlet with it though
where the hell is cold cow is there is
there Kevin
he's right here okay we haven't actually
modded cow sub care yeah I think the
Scimitar might be might be the one for
Kevin it's so cool it's not particularly
powerful I didn't need to be though it
looks great let's have a look-see I
wouldn't mess with that no way look at
that it's a great sword
that's an excellent sword so just give
you so many more options when you're
customizing your carrot to the beginning
so he really didn't look like the
classic vanilla Skyrim person at all and
I know that we've shown off these mods
before in previous episodes like
immersive armors and weapons and I know
that we kind of jumped straight to the
real high-end stuff that looks really
awesome but we skip all the low-level
stuff but for re-rolling it's really
important and it's really cool and and
of course you'll be able to continue
through and level and open up more
armors as you improve your smithing
skill so I think it's gonna be cool oh
god bring it bring it one Kevin come on
Kevin come on you're strong
you've gotta go oh no oh
down you go incidentally you might
noticed that kill move there mm-hmm in
the middle of combat that doesn't
normally happen nope that's cuz we've
got the dance of death is one of our
watch watch oh dear wait yankles and off
comes the throw does killing people in
Skyrim is never as fun unless you have
you have to have the kill me you have to
sound just great they're just great and
others cheese away from that guard yes
absolutely covered in blood serve as
well look at that look stunning a the
problem is of course the fur very
absorbent
yes very absorbent with blood and while
we hide down here beneath the rocks and
yes we should point out that obviously
that does with death has an MCN menu so
if we come inside here no you can then
change on the kill move chance we said
to 100 I'm at the cavitation chance I
love that that's a separate yeah
you just want to collect everyone's head
oh yeah that's an hour of initial
mammoth save me save Kevin Bernard from
the evil guard help alright it's hard
here behind the lavender oh no I
harvested 11 their run insatiable lemon
again was the death of me once again is
that what is that
yeah no run run Oh what falling moments
flying members dead man as members
forgot about that but oh god it's it's
all hell breaking loose in Skyrim we
forgot to install that no falling
mammoths mod 13 the crux of our show
there must be no way to see sorry horsie
oh god he's powerful he's more powerful
than I ever imagined you lie down and
think about what you've done
Wow don't get out of here that was risky
you guys didn't see anything no I said
the sword I just used a [ __ ] of that
poor horse is a horse is no ordinary
sword is an enchanted sword the sword of
horse bludgeoning yes I also known as
the iron grate sort of sapphic man one
of the mods you chosen is actually an
enchantment based mod and it changes the
appearance of your Chairman's you will
see enchanted Arsenal and chance at
Arsenal how things to do with the
football team everything to do with
making your weapons look cool wash all
my worries there you go it's look at
that the blue flames are planning I love
this mod yeah as so cool so this is
gonna stats app away everyone's magicka
and look I hi perfect example we'll take
oh nice haha and again though all you
should have learned from your friend but
you did not so this mod we've shown off
before and we covered it in a lot more
depth as well yeah but basically it does
just show off a variation of visual
effects based on the kind of enchantment
that you have on your weapons but where
this one's different to say see
enchantments yeah is it you can choose
from lots of different ones right and
you can customize it yes all of them are
customizable so you can say like alright
I want a different effect even with the
same enchantment depending on what I
have a dagger or an axe or anything like
that there's a overflowing magic right
there yeah
that's a lot a lot more subtle there
yeah but just it's a nice additional
visual effect I think to have on your
weapons and because it's so customizable
as well you can basically craft the
perfect look for any weapon you ever
have I said something that's been on
right from the beginning one of the mods
that been using today you might not have
noticed it but because it's job is to
hide it is of course immersive HUD I'm
not a big fan of HUD's and games
especially games that can look really
pretty
hmm so what this mod does is it yeah it
hides all the HUD when you're running
around but you can also customize it
because you notice if we were to come
across something it could be picked up
in fact tell you what as we're here on
the rock say I accidentally dropped my
iron scimitar Oh God no we can't lose
that you'll notice that actually you
know all the menus are there I can take
it I could cut that butterfly
everything's cafe D but it's there you
have a gala butterfly yeah exactly yes
fingers nimble lang and chopsticks snap
right are the air this screen is clear
of any Gump and you're just there to
drink in the beauty of murdering mud
crabs the slate look also look at the
size of that dead mud crab I'm a mud
crab just there that's the Queen they're
all dead night you can have a target if
using your sword or you can turn it off
for a bow you can have a crosshair on
that spell Oh useful I like to have it
off for the bow because I like the
challenge if you like the trick shots of
shooting Eagles haven't seen that guys
attempt so you got to set off like this
right and then you can't remember where
to go next
just hit X or whatever button you've
chosen and I'll show you where we're all
the icons are so toggle on just for a
sec and go like oh yeah I remember and
it's just like pulling out your
compasses your pocket and then
continuing on anyway uh it was fun it
wasn't me 40 goals at all haha take it
that's like half of the money we have
that's true yeah let's urban vanilla
Skyrim there are a lot of spells but
there's not loads of spells and we love
lo love loads of editing this one is
called apocalypse magic of Skyrim
normally he has quite a few books for
sale here but now he has tons already
yeah
you should join
just college in winter we were just
there was freezing we have a lot of it I
can't believe they let us in dress like
that no I'm cutting that much blood I
know it's kind of worrying like you
gotta you'll seem nice sab the best way
to show off our new spells with these
bandits my god
they dress themselves I know come on
fives is not decent let's put them in
the circle of scorn what what it's not
even doing is target inside the circle
luck loses ten percent attack damage and
the caster gains 10 percent per target
oh wow okay oh wow so we got a lot of
people in there so we could start
hurling punches brutal punch what else
have we got
ah bone spirit casts a vengeful spirit
their homes on a target explodes there
it is now I can see the spirit that
doesn't see me doing much damage no I've
seen angrier let's let our other things
do you funny for us minions
there he goes thanks pal avi goes yeah
very helpful now what happens when he
died oh oh yeah he's pretty he's pretty
strong huh he's lousy accurate but oh no
there he goes we summon him all the time
Lukas ghosts girl we gone pal vengeful
spirits girl he doesn't know who to kill
once he's killed he becomes the property
of whoever killed him yeah sorry I've
got plans
you can van nord dismisses you Oh
three more shells very very very
vulnerable in the belly yeah
now there's been quite a bit of oh and
it passes on so now he's ours again so
we never really go away I guess it's is
that it we've got him for life I guess
so um so loot Magnus one of my tribes
you've killed a few people around here
and this should bring all the loot in
the surrounding area to us well here
goes are we close enough and there we go
I can see it's actually working
do we have more stuff Oh II think we
definitely do we do we got a lot of
armor we got a yeah that's cool it's
brilliant that's such a clever idea
beyond foul demon Oh
oh no for you oh dear nope no he's back
no slay living should be should kill
things which are nearly dead
so now yes yeah Wow
I slew him because he was beneath 25%
hell that kind of reminds me of us kill
stealing I've like dota yeah when you um
when you sort of deny killing stuff like
that or last hit exactly well done
Shirl is annoying as you are sir if I
kill him now is that it's an infinite
loop uncle find her no it's just hideous
back and stronger and mad as hell haha
back hi Oh God oh no you're not be gone
I take a little look at oblivion and I'm
cause straight back in front of yourself
ah back for more huh please him anyway
lady doing it stop hi ah but please ow
ow every time I come back I feel pain
double well there we have it Seb are you
hen essential mods for re-rolling Skyrim
three years on happy birthday now I
think before we move on to rest of our
show we should run back through the ones
because yes so we started with a
alternate starter yes live another life
which of course we only did one version
of and it's like what 10 15 different
yeah and they're all really great going
straight on to the EMB pure light
maybe a little processor-intensive it
includes all the kind of climate stuff
as well so you get to have clothes
Tamriel so it's like an all an
all-in-one hence why it was so meaty and
power-hungry yes very very hungry indeed
we like me static mesh improvement which
which just fixes all of those blemishes
I really groups oh yeah get about it Oh
mod ha it is all about the ropes ah then
obviously 2k textures because things go
be pretty then immersive weapons and
armor technically to mods but from the
same guy so I feel like he's kind of
just gonna work out a dance of death
because you got to take heads sometimes
you just got to take a head mm-hmm onto
enchanted Arsenal because when you're
taking heads that sort of sometimes like
you're to be on fire yeah
sky you I so that you can organize your
fiery swords for taking heads yes
immersive HUD so there's nothing in the
way when you are taking
that crosshair is no air so you can
really see the taking of the head with
the fiery sword in all its glory and of
course apocalypse magic of Skyrim so
that once you've taken all the heads you
can can have a single spell to get all
the loot yes well done and that's your
10 essential mods bus that's our pink of
10 essential oils yes we love to hear
yours yeah well maybe we can showcase
some of your picked hands next week so I
send this a list didn't love to see them
I looked at a lot of the essential lists
um some of the stuff we've got on
there's the same some of the stuff is
different so yeah I'm expecting a lot of
people to disagree in fact so we didn't
have any NPC changes for example no
follower was one so I did actually try
and change yeah but because our save was
so so busted from how many mods we've
installed and removed in over the years
it just straight up didn't work yeah we
need the comments and feedback we do
okay and the first one comes from force
back to 13 wow that's forceful maybe you
guys were already planning something
like this but what do you think of
acting out and he's put that in quotes
acting out what you said to build your
own adventure after X number of entries
you know setting everything up in Skyrim
in guiding Kevin row for me I thought
you might be or she made meshing like in
real life I are acting happy Kevin he'll
head up the mounts and Kevin did I know
your own words yes yeah the next one
who's that from our second question is
from Ryan Barnes yes and he says damn it
said hi why aren't either of you
partaking in no-shave November
why isn't Kevin well good questions and
thanks for the old camp maybe maybe for
the next episode we put on a little mod
that give somebody a so anytime November
- miss - yes um I am NOT taking part
because I hate charity I'll in fact I'll
happily donate to anyone who's doing the
the No Shave November my bosses so I'm
gonna donate to him yeah I am incapable
of growing facial hair
ah it's adorable it's the truth after
three years I've kept it secret all this
time I have I'm the same I paint this on
every morning now I don't have any
excuse other than the fact that I look
really stupid with a mustache like the
point-like Reno but like released you
this is also
when the first times I've been I've been
single in November and I don't I don't
wanna I don't want to like most of my
chances with a with a really bad mother
back when you had the safety net
relation yeah it's not just to grow all
the mustaches all the ones I wanted
Caleb Rogers Jones hey Kalyan Rogers
come on I just feel like it's a good
name
what come on do y'all use when the
camera goes out and can go anywhere
y'all want without moving Kevin banner
field this one yeah this is toggle free
camera so hit tilde to bring up there
and console commands and then you hit
TFC toggle free camera yes and you can
fly around to your heart's content very
very useful and why you're in toggle
free camera if you then need to pass the
time as I mentioned last weeks you can
pass the time extra fast true yeah and
lastly someone going to touch they're
building a more diffuse mod they need
your help yes that's pretty much it they
need your help they need your help for
voting to get it pushed up ahead in a
competition and they need help building
it so if anyone is into building mods
this could be something that you might
want to check out yeah it's called I am
the king and it's currently on mod DB
calm
so if you go and check out I am The King
it's got a long way to go but it looks
like it could beat ya epic if you want
to however if you want to like have your
first kind of Florrie into modding and
help someone else side then maybe that
is the free for people making that at
the moment mm-hmm now what we haven't
done kin for a second weekend where oh
yes is we have it on the boat no no no
no it's another special we love specials
here any excuse although three is pretty
great excuse but we promise we will do
next yes definitely promise absolutely
and it's a good one the runaway Victor
at the moment awesome
Rimma but what we won't yield no is a
choose-your-own-adventure we've changed
it up for the first week since we
changed it cam yes you've written us a
story that's true so you guys voted last
week on what Kevin was gonna do next and
we have now written or I should say I
have no written a little ditty for you
guys it's not really a duty towards a
sentence but I like heaven love to write
although he didn't write Scrolls ballads
or stories he wrote ditties yes
so last week how did it go said well
last we left we were left thusly hmm
Kevin's skin is impenetrable as skyforge
steel his expression never deviating
from that of determination as he began
his ascent and we were given three
choices what happens next ness choosing
to go back the way he came catching
sight of a flame atop the mountain ridge
or getting a merry tune stuck in his
head and the winner was cam the winner
was said in fact I'll go from here he
didn't suddenly change his mind and
decided to go back again so I have then
written in the next part and I will
leave you some options for you guys to
choose what happened next
okay so he decided to go back again for
he had an itch he did an itch for blood
for blood sustained him
just the mere sight of it would bring a
tear to his eye if his body were capable
of producing tears which it can't he
broke into a gallop on all four he
strode as he raced toward dot-dot-dot
where was he going okay option number
one he was racing towards white run
naturally option number two a gaggle of
Lydia's they are always seen in a gaggle
number three a loon majestic chicken or
number four the boat - so sty so where
is it going white run
Lydia's chicken or solstein up to you
absolutely and you can vote on where he
goes next by going to tinyurl.com /cam
Fras blog can browse blog you'd set a
ready savvy blog for the vast mod and it
is camp res blog for the store it's easy
it's so simple so I'll be like these
things very straightforward here and put
my summers all the links to be adult
cheap description as if you get confused
just tweet us if you want to tweet us
you can tweet at me at cam for as Rob
and you can tweet me at Ready Steady Go
that's also the place if you have mods
you want to suggest hmm just any
comments about maybe how you like Seb's
hair or send pictures of the mustaches
that i yeah never grow
play even better well Sabbats say I like
birthdays but I'll or face must come to
an end yes with cake I wonder if we'll
still be doing a show when scarm turns
four that's a good question having elder
scrolls or maybe probably not that but
we may have a new game from the folks at
Bethesda maybe fallout 4 to coincide
with a fourth birthday of Skyrim that
would be so no incident probably but who
knows we don't know which end but well
maybe we'll be hey maybe by next week
wall knows and make sure you join us
then it's lately more top 5 scary more
to the week
you